bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat elle veut jeter un pavé dans la
mare et en finir avec les idées reçues
il s'agit de la sénatrice écologiste
esther benbassa avec sa proposition de
loi sur le cannabis la première de ce
type ici au sénat que propose cette
proposition de loi est bien d'autoriser
la vente au détail de cannabis mais dans
un cadre strictement contrôlés
l'objectif de la sénatrice est simple en
finir avec ce qu'elle appelle la
politique de l'autruche quand on sait
que chaque année en france environ 13
millions de personnes
expérimenté le cannabis mais la
sénatrice se fait assez peu d'illusions
elle sait que sa proposition de loi
assez peu de chances d'être adopté après
le rejet du texte en commission les
débats étaient parfois houleux dans
l'hémicycle
je propose aujourd'hui est bien de
revoir la séance tout de suite direction
l'hémicycle l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion de la proposition de loi
autorisant l'usagé contrôlée du cannabis
présenté par madame esther benbassa et
plusieurs de ses collègues à la demande
du groupe écologiste dans la discussion
générale la parole et à esther benbassa
du groupe écologiste et auteur de la
proposition de loi
madame benbassa vous avez la parole
et c'est invraisemblable donc j'ai vu
qu'elle était tombée
monsieur le président madame la
secrétaire d'état monsieur le président
de la commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le rapporteur michel collègues
le 28 28 janvier 2014 il y a un an je
déposé au nom du groupe écologie sur le
bureau du sénat
la première proposition de loi visant à
autoriser l'usagé contrôlée du cannabis
l'idée est le texte de cette ppl ont
émergé dans le contexte des débats ayant
fait qu'accompagner les efforts
accomplis dans cette direction par
l'uruguay jusqu'à l'adoption le 10
décembre 2013 de la loi 19 172 qui
confie à l'état le contrôle et la
régulation de l'importation de la
production de l'acquisition du stockage
de la commercialisation et de la
distribution du cannabis
peu après en janvier 14 2014 bien sûr
l'état du colorado a adopté à son tour
des dispositions instituant une
légalisation contrôlée à les suivre
bientôt
la légalisation dans l'état de
washington au printemps 2014 l'entrée en
vigueur de la loi uruguayenne à
l'automne 2014
comme si un mouvement désormais
inéluctable commencé à se dessiner
auquel se joignirent à leur tour
l'alaska l'orégon et washington dc
capitale des usa la france n'était pas à
l'abri de cette évolution dès 2011
daniel vaillant rédigé un rapport
significativement intitulé pour mieux
lutter contre le cannabis sortir de
l'hypocrisie
d'autres l'ont suivi y compris après le
dépôt de la présente ppl je cite le
rapport d'information sur l'évaluation
de la lutte contre l' usage de
substances illicites de nos collègues
députés madame anne yvonne le dain et
monsieur laurent marcangeli en novembre
2014 puis se
de terra nova en décembre 2014 sans
compter bien sûr la riche documentation
scientifique et statistiques existant
sur le sujet depuis des années
l'initiative qui nous vaut d'ouvrir ici
un débat effectivement crucial qui
interpelle toutes les strates de notre
société et les pouvoirs publics
eux-mêmes n'est pas sortie de la tête
embrumée ou en fumée d'une écologiste
présumait amatrice de juin comme le
voudraient certains clichés
elle est le fruit d'un long cheminement
depuis leur entrée dans cette haute
assemblée
les écologistes ont lancé un débat sur
maints sujets juin le rôle d'aiguillon
qu'ils affectionnent et guillon nous le
sommes donc à nouveau aujourd'hui je
cite avec 13,4 millions d'
expérimentateurs des près de 4 millions
de consommateurs le cannabis est devenue
malgré son interdiction
un produit de consommation courante
comme le tabac et l'alcool
l'hypocrisie du statu quo n'est plus
tenable
la loi de 1970 sens c'est de protéger la
société de la toxicomanie a totalement
échoué
en ce domaine le laxisme consisterait à
ne pas voir ce qui nous saute aux yeux
et à s'interdire tout débat sur un sujet
pétant du monde tabou ce qui reviendrait
à abandonner les français sans leur
offrir de véritables réponses
alternatives et ce n'est pas moi qui le
dit ni quelques libertés divaguant non
juste l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
daniel vaillant dans les trous dans
l'introduction de son rapport de 2011 en
déposant la ppl dont nous débattons
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas eu d'autre
objectif vous convaincre jal collègues
de sortir de cette forme de laxisme de
fait que dénonce daniel vaillant le
problème que le présenter
ce temple d'affronter comporte de
multiples aspects à cet égard plus d'une
commission de notre assemblée aurait pu
légitimement en est saisi son examen a
finalement été confié à la commission
des affaires sociales
ce qui ne saurait étonner le cannabis
est aussi et peut être avant tout une
question de santé publique
le rapporteur jean désessard a réalisé
un remarquable travail que je tiens à
saluer
de fait quand à ceux qui me concerne
c'est précisément entre autres motive la
conviction que le cannabis n'est
assurément pas un produit anodin la
conscience claire du fait qu'il contient
des substances psychotropes
potentiellement dangereuses pour la
santé notamment celle des plus jeunes
dont le cerveau est encore en formation
qui m'ont décidé à m'atteler à la
rédaction de la ppl que j'ai donc
l'honneur de défendre devant vous
reste que madame la ministre des
affaires sociales de la santé et des
droits des femmes ne nous honore pas de
sa présence
c'est madame la secrétaire d'état
chargée des droits des femmes qui la
représente
seul pascal boitard nous nous
connaissons de longue date et nous nous
estimons je crois mutuellement
mais quel est l'apport du canin le
cannabis at-il dont avec les droits des
femmes qui soit dit en passant qui soit
dit en passant les femmes sont moins
consommatrices que les hommes de rapport
je l'envoie bière et si je me réjouis de
vous voir chef pascal boitard je n'ai
pas à chercher très loin
les motifs de l'absence de madame
touraine laquelle déclarait il y à peu
sur bfm
je la cite je ne suis pas favorable à ce
qu'on mette ce débat sur la table
aujourd'hui maintenons le droit tel
qu'il est il ne me sens pas judicieux
comme message à envoyer de dire qu'au
fond le cannabis ce n'est pas si grave
que cela
et bien si le débat est sur la table est
le message que nous envoyons n'est pas
celui que le doute madame touraine nous
avons choisi nous écologistes de
regarder le problème en face les
françaises et français eux mêmes ont
brisé le tabou et il s'interroge ce qui
est très important
ainsi la part des personnes estimant que
l' usage du cannabis comporte un risque
dès l'expérimentation et est-il en
baisse 54 % actuellement contre 62% en
2008 les opinions des français sur les
politiques publiques menées ou à mener
en matière de drogues traduisent un
double mouvement
d'un côté une plus forte adhésion aux
mesures prohibitives consciemment le
tabac et l'alcool
et parallèlement un suffrage moins
marquée aux sanctions prévues par la loi
pour les personnes interpellées pour
usage ou détention de cannabis
les français restent très
majoritairement opposés à une mise en
vente libre du cannabis
78 % la proportion de ceux qui sont
favorables 22 % a pourtant nettement
progressé depuis 2008 où elle était de
15% la part d'opinions favorables à
l'autorisation du cannabis sous
certaines conditions en maintenant
l'interdiction pour les mineurs et avant
de conduire a quant à elle doublé sur la
période passant de 31 % à 60 %
même parmi les personnes opposées à la
mise en vente libre du cannabis une
partie plus importante qu'en 2008 serait
d'accord pour une mise en vente libre
sous conditions enfin d'après l'enquète
elop
les français apparaissent de plus en
plus réservé à l'égard des différentes
sanctions qui punissent la consommation
simple j'entends sans revendre avec une
préférence pour les solutions qui
oriente vers les soins ou
rappel à la loi assurer avant tout la
santé et la sécurité des personnes et
des collectivités
le caire une réorientation fondamentale
des priorités et des ressources des
politiques mises en oeuvre
les dépenses induites par les
dispositions punitive en vigueur
inefficace contre productive et coûteuse
pour le contribuable devrait cesser
alors que celle consacrée aux mesures
éprouvées de prévention de réduction des
rides et de traitement devrait au
contraire augmenté pour couvrir les
besoins
heymans n'oublions pas que 41 ans et
demi pour cent des jeunes de 17 ans ont
expérimenté le cannabis et que six et
demi pour cent des fumeurs sont
réguliers tant 2,8 pour cent des adultes
de 18 à 64 ans ont expérimenté le
cannabis et 2,1 pour cent sont des
fumeurs réguliers au moins 38 mille
personnes sont prises en charge en
raison de leur consommation de cannabis
dans les structures spécialisées
spécialisé en addictologie
commençons par éradiquer quelques-uns
des préjugés et ayant la logique absurde
de la prohibition
la théorie de l'escaladé par exemple
selon laquelle le consommateur de
cannabis en cas de dépénalisation et ou
de légalisation du cannabis aurait
nécessairement recours à des substances
plus dangereuse
cette théorie ne tient pas la
consommation de cannabis et old est
ordinairement transitoire est même en
cas de dépendance
les deux tiers des usagers médecins à
leur addiction
entre 25 et 30 ans on nous disait je
cite les ados vont se ruer sur le
cannabis les adultes vont se défoncer et
ne plus aller travailler
rien de tout cela ne s'est concrétisé
voilà ce que ce que constate il ya peu
envie tu étais l'un des rédacteurs de
l'amendement 64 par lequel 57 55 % des
électeurs du colorado ont autorisé la
production et la vente du cannabis aux
adultes de plus de 21 ans au tibet a
révoqué en doute l'extrême dangerosité
du cannabis le cannabis nous tue
quasiment pas en comparaison avec des
drogues comme l'héroïne et la cocaïne
sa dangerosité est moindre que celle du
tabac et de l'alcool
salt conduit sous l'influencé du
cannabis multiplie par 1,8 par 1,8 le
risque d'être responsable d'un accident
mortel de la route
mais il est multiplié par près de 15 en
cas de consommation conjointe de
cannabis et d'alcool selon les experts
européens
l'alcool serait de loin le produit le
plus dangereux entraînant des dommages
sanitaires et sociaux majeurs suivi par
l'héroïne et la cocaïne puis par le
tabac qui causeraient surtout des
dommages sanitaires seulement ensuite
viendrait le cannabis susceptibles de
causer plutôt des dommages sociétaux set
et je l' ai déjà dit le cannabis n'est
pas un produit anodin
l' expertise de l'inserm sur les
conduites addictives chez les jeunes
souligne que l'excès de consommation
entraîne chez eux déficit de l'activité
fatigue physique intellectuel difficulté
de mémorisation difficultés
relationnelles décrochage scolaire mal
est il peut également induire des
troubles psychotiques lui aussi au
parcours du vie de l'adolescent à sa vie
de famille etc
en revanche il n'a pas été démontré que
le cannabis pouvait être la cause unique
de la schizophrénie et bien justement
pour lutter contre ces maux il ne s'agit
pas d'interdît
est de punir mais de prévenir et de
guérir mieux on ne pourra jamais
efficacement prévenir et guérir qu'en
levant le tabou et en cessant
d'interdire pour encadrer et contrôler
la dangerosité du tabac et de l'alcool
n'ont pourtant pas induit le leur
interdiction ni la pénalisation
on connaît les effets pervers de la
prohibition de l'alcool aux états unis
dans les années 20 les pouvoirs publics
s'attelle aujourd'hui avec raison bien
sûr à des campagnes de prévention
probablement plus utile pourquoi ne pas
agir de même avec le cannabis
la guerre menée contre les drogues
depuis 40 ans n'a réussi ni à limiter
leur consommation ni endiguer la
criminalité liées à leur production et à
leur commerce
les interpellations pour usage de
cannabis atteignent le chiffre annuel de
122 1439 elles représentent 90% des
interpellations pour usage de
stupéfiants leur nombre a été multiplié
par cinq depuis le début des années 1990
en dehors des affaires d'usagé les
services de police et de gendarmerie ont
effectué 15300 deux interpellations pour
usage revente et trafic de cannabis
cent quinze mille personnes ont été
condamnées en 2012 à des peines inscrite
au casier judiciaire pour consommation
de cannabis
le premier constat qui s'impose et celui
du désert du modèle répressif français
notre police et notre justice long tail
pas mieux à faire
n'avons nous donc aucun souci de l'
usage des deniers publics
le niveau de prévalence du cannabis en
france est parmi les plus élevés
europe avec le danemark un collégien
français sur dix a expérimenté le
cannabis
et si cette consommation ne touche qu'un
an et demi pour cent des élèves en 6e
elle en touche
un sur quatre en troisième pire notre
stratégie de prévention nationale et
d'accompagnement des usagers est quasi
inexistante faute de ressources au
colorado 33 millions d'euros du produit
des taxes du cannabis légalisé ont été
alloués aux écoles et je cite nous
sommes guidés par trois principes éviter
que la marijuana ne tombent entre les
mains des enfants des criminels et des
autres états a déclaré la directrice de
l'administration fiscale de l'état du
colorado
n'y at il donc pas lieu de s'inspirer
d'une telle expérience au sein de
l'union européenne on rencontre trois
sortes de législation celle qui
considère l'usagé de cannabis comme une
infraction pénale
celle qui considère cet usage comme une
infraction administrative passible de
sanctions administratives
enfin dans 15 pays membres de l'union
européenne
usage du cannabis en tant que telle
n'est pas interdit par la loi mais sa
détention en petites quantités pour
usage personnel constitue une infraction
pénale ou administrative
aux pays-bas la détention et la vente de
cannabis ne sont pas légales mais elles
sont tolérés sous certaines conditions
la hollande n'a jamais légalisé la
production du cannabis sur son
territoire et ne s'intéresse pas aux
sources d'approvisionnement des coffee
shops qui relève d'une réglementation
nationale honnie de nobles moins de neuf
mille interpellations pour infractions
relatives aux drogues douces en 2012
pour l'ensemble du pays dix-huit mille
trois cent pour l'ensemble des drogues
soit dix fois moins
en france j'ajoute pour finir que la
prévalence du cannabis est inférieure en
hollande à celle constatée chez nous
13,7 pour cent sur les douze derniers
mois
pour les 15 34 ans contre dix sept et
demi en france malgré une légalisation
législation infiniment plus répressives
et aucune tolérance pour la vente libre
la présente proposition de loi a pour
objet d'autoriser l'usagé et d'encadrer
de manière très rigoureuse la vente au
détail aux personnes majeures et l'
usage de plants de cannabis et de
produits dérivés issus des cultures de
culture est de pratiques culturales
contrôler et donc les caractéristiques
et la teneur en principe si qu'aux
actifs ou le thc serait réglementée
nous avons depuis peu plusieurs exemples
de dépénalisation et de légalisation
contrôlée du cannabis
l'uruguay adopté un ensemble de loi
légalisant et réglementant les usages
non médicaux du cannabis
le modèle uruguayen réponse repose sur
un degré d'intervention gouvernemental
plus élevé que les modèles commerciaux
des états de washington et du colorado
aux états unis et ce dans tout le
circuit allant de la production à la
vente
les recettes liées au cannabis ont été
vains 2014 au colorado de 570 millions
d'euros selon une estimation
le rapport de terra nova envisage quant
à lui la légalisation du cannabis et la
structuration de monopole public avec
les meilleures garanties en termes de
contrôle de la prévalence est de
pratiquer protection des peuples des
populations les plus vulnérables
il faudrait également assécher le marché
noir de quelque cent mille personnes en
baissant dans un premier temps le prix
du gramme de cannabis légal puis
l'augmenter comme le tas
à afin d'empêcher la l'augmentation de
la prévalence c'est l'égalisation serait
une source de revenus fiscaux
considérables qui se situerait entre 1,7
milliard et 2 milliards d'euros et
généreux la création d'au moins treize
mille emplois or ceux liés à la
production sans compter le coup porté au
réseau de la drogue à la criminalité qui
leur est associé et à l'une des sources
de financement du terrorisme
cette ppl est la première du genre avec
des pauses et débattus dans l'histoire
parlementaire française j'espère de tout
coeur chers collègues que vous lui
apporterez vos suffrages
mais quand bien même vous hésiteriez à
le faire l'examen de ce texte
contribuera indéniablement à
l'indispensable processus de
sensibilisation de l'opinion publique et
des responsables politiques à une
question sociétale sociale et sanitaire
crucial
le débat est donc ouvert publiquement et
au plus haut niveau
voilà qui est fort bien merci
kc madame anne bassa
la parole est à monsieur 2 c'est sa
rapporteure de la commission des
affaires sociales
ce président madame la ministre
et mes chers collègues tout d'abord je
vais remercier la commission des
affaires sociales de m'avoir désigné
rapporteur sur un tel sujet
j'ai pu ainsi réaliser 22 audition très
intéressante
effectivement qu'ils partageaient pas le
même point de vue et je peux dire que le
débat comme l'a dit madame benbassa ne
fait que s'engager j'espère qu'il aura
une issue positive aujourd'hui mais en
tout cas se sentit qu'effectivement il y
avait le souhait que ce point soit
abordée et qu'effectivement il ya une
information complète sur ce sujet la
france fait partie des plus gros
consommateurs de cannabis en europe avec
13,4 millions d' expérimentateurs 1,2
million d'usagers réguliers et sa cent
mille consommateurs quotidiens parmi les
11 75 ans ce produit s'est banalisé et
son usage concerne désormais les milieux
sociaux les plus divers la question du
statut légal de cannabis est aujourd'hui
clairement posée dans la société et nous
avons d'ailleurs eu des échanges très
intéressants
en commission les fêtes nous invite en
effet à nous extraire de nos
représentations courante pour regarder
la situation avec pragmatisme et nous
interroger sur les changements
nécessaires
la disponibilité croissante de l'herbe
de cannabis est en partie liée au
développement de l'auto culture
le nombre de cas nabil cannabiculteurs
se situant entre 100 et 200 mille selon
les estimations
la fourchette est large mais vous
comprendrez qui vont pas se déclarer
donc la majeure partie du cannabis en
circulation demeure qu'une fois issu du
trafic international représentant les
trois quarts du revenu du trafic des
drogues ce trafic sont criminalisés en
lien avec la grande délinquance des
réseaux mafieux entretiennent une
véritable économie parallèle qui
déstabilise la vie de certaines cités
avec un chiffre d'affaires estimé à 832
millions d'euros à la fin des années
2000 pour une quantité vendue évalué
environ 200 tonnes le cannabis draine
des intérêts financiers considérables
dans ce domaine nos pays a pourtant
adopté et c'est le paradoxe il y à plus
de 40 ans l'un des dispositifs
répressifs les plus sévères en europe
depuis la loi du 31 décembre 70 l'usagé
de cannabis est pénalisée au même titre
que n'importe quel autre stupéfiants
nous en discutons chers collègues nous
en discutons il constitue un délit et
tout contrevenant s'expose à une peine
d'un an d'emprisonnement et de 3750
euros damende la détention est quant à
elle puni de dix ans d'emprisonnement et
d'une amende de 7 5 millions d'euros
en pratique l'application de ces règles
mobilise des ressources considérables
sans parvenir à juguler la consommation
et c'est la cire collègues et
l'interrogation plus grands
consommateurs en europe
et pourtant la plus grande répression
d'europe
il y à là même un paradoxe l'opinion des
français eux-mêmes à évoluer sur
l'observatoire français la part de nos
concitoyens qui estime que l'on pourrait
autoriser l'usagé de cannabis sur
certaines conditions
seulement pour les usagers majeurs et
l'interdire sous d'autres avant de
conduire ou pour les mineurs s'élève
aujourd'hui à 60 % contre 30 % en 2008
il ya une évolution de l'opinion
chers collègues sur ce point de 60% par
rapport à 30% en 2008
la proposition de loi qui nous réunit
cet après-midi up pour une stratégie de
réduction des dommages à travers une
régulation par l'état comme nous
l'indiqué son auteur notre collègue
esther benbassa elle autorise la vente
au détail dans le cadre d'un monopole de
l'état et l'ush âge à des fins non
thérapeutiques de plants de cannabis ou
du produit du cannabis dont les
caractéristiques seraient définies par
décret un strict encadrement sanitaire
est prévu avec en particulier
l'interdiction de la vente aux mineurs
afin de renforcer la prévention des
risques auprès des jeunes
le texte propose par ailleurs
d'augmenter la fréquence des sessions
d'informations délivrées en milieu
scolaire sur les conséquences de la
consommation de drogue sur la santé
j'insiste dans ce projet de loi il ne
s'agit ni de libéraliser le cannabis
solution qui de fait ne changerait pas
grand-chose à situation actuelle ni deux
le dépénaliser il s'agit au contraire
d'une légalisation contrôlée par l'état
dont l'une des raisons principales est
de lutter contre les mafias et les
trafics et donc contre la sécurité qui
en découlent nous avons eu le débat en
commission des affaires sociales
satar dit pourquoi ne pas dépénalisées
mais ça règle pas le problème numéro un
quel problème des mafias quel problème
de la sécurité dans les quartiers
qu'est ce que vous faites je suis vous
dépénaliser vous autorisez les à
consommer mais le marché la production
le transport
ce sont toujours les mafias qui le font
chacun interviendra et si vous ne vous
allez dans mon sens voilà effectivement
si c'est effectivement clandestins et
bien le dealer lui et il n'hésite pas à
proposer d'autres substances
par contre si c'est un marché et si
c'est un marché contrôlé et bien n'allez
pas la personne ne va pas proposer
d'autres substances
donc là tout ce que fait donc la
dépénalisation nous en avons discuté en
commission des affaires sociales ne
règle pas le problème des mafias ne
règle pas le problème de la sécurité et
cette loi d'une légalisation contrôlée
règle c'est seulement ce problème
puisque la production le transport sont
contrôlées par l'état
si c'est légal on peut faire de la
prévention
comme pour l'alcool aujourd'hui comme
pour le tabac sortir le marché du
cannabis de la clandestinité permettra
en outre de mieux accompagner les
usagers et d'encadrer la consommation je
les dis en commission parmi l'ensemble
des personnes avec laquelle je me suis
entretenu ce sont les acteurs qui sont
le plus étroitement en contact avec des
usagers de cannabis qui accueille le
plus favorablement la proposition la
fédération addiction par exemple qui
regroupe les professionnels du terrain
juge que la mise en place d'une
politique de régulation en limitant
l'accès par une action sur les prix et
les règles de publicité serait plus
efficace qu'une action publique
écartelés entre une prohibition
théorique et à marseille tout puissant
c'est la fédération des addictions
ce ne sont pas les mots du rapporteur
une prohibition théorie pourquoi est-ce
que tu cher collègue
interrogeons nous sur le fait qu'on a la
répression la plus grave qu'on a des
mafias et pourtant dans la plus grande
consommation de cannabis en europe
c'est là le problème
la proposition de loi me semble en effet
constituer une réponse équilibrée
au delà de l'anr l'alternative stérile
entre simple des penne la dépénalisation
qui ne règle rien et propositions à tout
prix qui n'a pas réglé le problème
jusqu'à maintenant je suis donc
favorable à la proposition de loi
présentée par madame esther benbassa
mais je dois quand même en tant que
rapporteur vous donner le point de vue
de la commission c'est un collègue qui
arrive mercredi dernier les travaux
menés par la commission des affaires
sociales ont montré l'existence de
divergences
et oui oui oui sur les évolutions à
apporter au système actuel et la
commission effectivement n'a pas
souhaité donner une suite favorable à la
proposition de loi qui lui étaient
soumises certains d'entre nous adam
d'entre eux entre vous de la commission
estime en effet que la prévention est
préférable à la légalisation qui
enverrait un mauvais signal à nos
concitoyens dans les sociétés en manque
de repères d'autres se félicite de
l'ouverture de ce débat et soulignent la
difficulté de concilier les enjeux
d'ordre public avec les enjeux de santé
publique
la piste d'une transformation de la
plaine d'usagers de cannabis en une
simple contravention a été évoqué à
plusieurs reprises quand ce n'est pas la
nécessité de traiter d'abord de ces
questions au niveau international qui a
été mise en avant les multiples
arguments assez avancé témoigne à mon
sens de la richesse de nos débats sur
une question qu'il est aujourd'hui
permis d'aborder avec sérieux mes chers
collègues il y a urgence
et oui il ya urgence on peut dire
d'abord ses quarante ans de luttes
stériles et que pourquoi il ya urgence
parce qu'il ya la sécurité dans les
quartiers parce qu'il ya développement
des mafias iriya des risques de
corruption
à très court terme déjà déjà c'est pas
tout la police et vidéo en cause mais
déjà des douaniers sont arrêtés déjà des
policiers sont mis en cause par rapport
au cannabis le risque de corruption
c'est vraiment quelque chose de qui va
se poser dans les prochaines années
nous ne pouvons pas rester à rien faire
devant le cette mafia qui se développe
qui est organisée qui gangrène de
multiples quartiers donc il faudra qu'on
prenne un jour vraiment une décision
pragmatique en toute lucidité
je me félicite que le constat des
limites de la politique actuelle soit
globalement partagée et que nos échanges
sur cette question multifactorielle est
donc complexe ait pu s'engager sur des
bases communes et donc si je peux
regretter la décision de la commission
je dois dire qu'effectivement la
position de la commission n'est pas
favorable à l'adoption de cette
proposition de loi et je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est à monsieur milon président de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues pendant longtemps l'image de
cannabis et de ses produits dérivés a
été celle d'une drogue douce récréative
sans danger pour la santé
les nombreux travaux scientifiques menés
au cours des dernières années ont
cependant mis en lumière une toute autre
réalité
je souhaite revenir quelques instants
sur ces risques sanitaires bien réelle
en rappelant simplement l'état des
connaissances médicales sur la nocivité
du cannabis pour les personnes les plus
fragiles c'est dommage se traduisent
essentiellement par des troubles
cognitifs et psychiatriques dont la
sévérité varie selon les quantités
consommées
selon l'âge d'exposition et selon les
vulnérabilité particulière de chaque
individu
à cet égard la jeunesse constitue une
période particulièrement critique
le processus de maturation cérébrale qui
on peut dire bat son plein à
l'adolescence est sûr poursuit au delà
permet aux jeunes d'acquérir les
compétences physiques et intellectuelles
qui lui seront indispensables dans sa
vie d'adulte
or le thc principe actif principal du
cannabis interagit avec ce développement
ce qui peut conduire à des anomalies de
la substance grise et de la substance
blanche c'est-à-dire du système cérébral
et neurologiques
si des troubles de l'attention et de la
mémoire peuvent survenir dans les six
heures suivant une prise unique
ils sont d'autant plus importants que la
consommation a débuté précocement
or la première expérimentation de
l'usagé du cannabis se fait à un âge de
plus en plus précoce
lorsqu'elle s'accompagne d'un syndrome à
motivationnelle des intérêts manque
d'engagement ces difficultés sont
susceptibles en cas de consommation
régulière de causer ou d'aggraver le
décrochage scolaire voire la
désinsertion sociale
les conséquences sont graves lorsque ces
troubles sont à l'origine d'accidents
d'avoirs publics
je rappelle mais vous le savez tous que
l' usage conjoint du cannabis et
d'alcool multiplie par 14 le risque de
se rendre responsable d'un accident
mortel de la route
en ce qui concerne les effets du
cannabis sur le psychisme le risque de
survenue d tad angoisse aiguë est avérée
une constatation clinique fréquentes et
celle de symptômes psychotiques tech des
idées de persécution des idées
d'hostilité de l'entourage voir des
sensations de dépersonnalisation et plus
rarement des hallucinations
une étude portant sur des étudiants
indique que ses effets sont plus
important lorsque les sujets présentent
une vulnérabilité particulière à la
psychose les liens entre le cannabis et
la schizophrénie quant à eux ont
longtemps été controversée
une première étude célèbre réalisée en
1987 par an de renson sur une large
population de conscrits suédois
établissez un lien statistique entre
exposition au cannabis et risques
ultérieurs de schizophrénie cette
attitude a été critiquée pour ses biais
des travaux épidémiologique ultérieures
ont néanmoins permis d'affiner les
résultats et en résulte que
l'augmentation du risque de troubles
psychotiques dépend de nombreux facteurs
et connotés le cannabis pourrait révéler
ou aggraver une schizophrénie latente
enfin comme pour le tabac et l'alcool
la plupart des conséquences somatiques
surviennent généralement plusieurs
dizaines d'années après le début d'une
consommation régulière les effets
carcinogènes induits par le cannabis
sont indépendants de ceux liés au tabac
plusieurs études récentes ont en outre
montré que la consommation de cannabis
pourrait favoriser la survenue
d'infarctus du myocarde
elle peut aussi être à l'origine
d'accidents vasculaires cérébraux par
angiopathie cérébrale enfin il faut lui
ni souligné aussi que l'appétence des
usagers pour des produits de plus en
plus dosée en thc ainsi que l'émergence
de cannabinoïdes synthétiques n'augure
rien de bon quant à l'évolution de la
dangerosité
bien au contraire voici en quelques mots
monsieur le président mais d'un ministre
mes chers collègues les est mort les
éléments en notre possession sur
l'impact sanitaire de la consommation de
cannabis
dès lors faut-il revoir le régime légal
et pénales applicables en france à l'
usage du cannabis
cette question est rapporteur l'adie a
suscité de riches débats en commission
je remercie d'ailleurs le rapporteur
jean desessard pour la très grande
qualité de son rapport son travail est à
la fois documenté précis et objectifs
il a suscité à gif atterré et a permis à
chacun d'entre nous de faire avancer ses
réflexions à partir du constat largement
partagé des limites du cadre actuel de
solides arguments ont été avancés de
part et d'autre sur une question
difficile qui n'appellent pas de réponse
totalement évidente comme le montre la
diversité des législations nationales
un assouplissement du cadre légal
certains l'ont souligné paraît très
contradictoire avec le message de
prévention et rendrait tout retour en
arrière particulièrement difficile mais
la réponse pénale actuelle cela est vrai
aussi conduit à des impasses
notre collègue laurence cohen
ancien rapporteur des crédits note de la
mission interministérielle de lutte
contre la drogue et la toxicomanie la
1000 de l'époque nous a rappelé son
travail avec les fédérations de la
théologie
vous l'avez dit des professionnels du
terrain appellent de leurs voeux un
grand débat public sur les questions des
drogues qui restent trop souvent traités
de manière superficielle sous l'angle du
sensationnel il semble en effet que la
criminalisation des usagers fassent
obstacle à l'accès aux soins et à la
prévention
je tiens également à saluer pour sa
contribution à viser l'actuel rapporteur
de la mine des cas gilbert barbier dans
le prolongement de son excellent rapport
d'information de 2011 sur la question
des toxicomanes et des toxicomanies il a
pointé la nécessité de changer le
système et d'approfondir la démarche de
sensibilisation des jeunes et de leurs
familles hodanger connu au terme d'une
discussion nourrie la commission des
affaires sociales n'a pas approuvé le
dispositif proposé par notre collègue
esther benbassa elle ne reconnaît pas
moi le besoin d'une stratégie cohérente
d'un ministre à l'égard d'un produit
dans la consommation est loin d'être
anodine notamment pour les jeunes je
voudrais ajouter que le rapporteur
justifie le projet doit la proposition
de loi du fait de la légalisation par
ailleurs du tabac et de l'alcool il ya
des années en arrière pour rappeler
d'abord que la consommation d'alcool n'a
jamais été légalisé pour tout début de
sa consommation
c'est une consommation traditionnelle
notre pays en europe
est ce que la légalisation des revenus
que par la suite mais lorsque le tabac a
été légalisé ceux qui ont légalisé le
tabac ne connaissait pas le danger
notamment ils ont légalisé parce qu'il
pensait que le tabac était quelque chose
de bien et qu'il n'y avait pas de danger
pour la santé
je voudrais vous rappeler les chiffres
du plfss 2015 que nous avons voté
dernièrement en
octobre novembre 2014 c'est vrai que la
légalisation du cannabis pourrait
rapporter 1 milliard 500 millions
d'euros à l'état
c'est comme ça que c'est justifié pour
l'égalisation le tabac rapporte lui 11
milliards d'euros à l'état mais dans le
même temps il ya 73 mille décès par an à
cause du tabac mais dans le même temps
les dépenses de santé pour le tabac ces
20 milliards
c'est à dire 9 milliards de plus que les
recettes des mais en même temps les
économies se vous disent que le coût de
global pour l'économie française du
tabac ces 47 milliards c'est donc que
quelque chose de considérable dont il
faut avoir en tête en permanence
autorisé quelque chose parce qu'on ne
trouve pas la façon de faire autrement
et parce que ça pourrait rapporter de
l'argent ne me semble pas être une bonne
solution je vote contre cette
proposition de loi
bien que je concède que le fait d'avoir
soulevé le problème est extrêmement
important et juste
mais la proposition telle qu'elle est
faite nous aurons dans quelques années
peut-être si nous sommes encore en vie
l'occasion de voir ça va dépendre
ça demande beaucoup d'années parfois
pour que les problèmes arrivent mais
dans quelques années peut-être nous
aurions l'occasion de regretter de
devoir fait ce que vous nous proposez
aujourd'hui donc je voterai avec le
groupe ump d'ailleurs contre ce projet
cette composition en dix ans une fois de
plus qu'il fallait en effet soulevé le
problème est que d'autres solutions
doivent être trouvées
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à pascale boitard secrétaire d'état
chargée des droits des femmes
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur madame
la sénatrice esther benbassa mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
la consommation de substances
psychoactives si elle est présentée
comme culturel signe d'émancipation
usage récréatif est particulière en ce
sens qu'elle génère une dépendance chez
les consommateurs et vous l'avez tous
souligné chaque substance a ses propres
caractéristiques
qu'il s'agisse de la vitesse d'entrée
dans la dépendance
les conséquences directes de la
consommation sur les comportements etc
néanmoins nul ne peut ignorer les
conséquences sanitaires dramatique des
conduites addictives et particulièrement
de la consommation de drogues les
consommations de drogues évolué et nous
sommes confrontés de plus en plus aux
polyconsommation le cannabis est loin et
de loin la substance illicite la plus
consommée dix fois plus que la cocaïne
ou de l'ecstasy les substances
psychoactives les plus consommés en
france reste le tabac et l'alcool est il
encore nécessaire de rappeler à cette
tribune
les nombreuses maladies chroniques
générés par ces comportements cancers
maladies cardiovasculaires respiratoires
maladies du foie maladie neurologique
troubles psychiatriques
n'oublions pas les conséquences que
peuvent avoir l'injection de drogues
intraveineuses notamment la transmission
de virus tels que le vih et les
hépatites
nous sommes réunis cet après midi pour
examiner la proposition de loi déposée
par le groupe écologiste visant à
autoriser un usage contrôlée du cannabis
ce texte par pourtant d'un constat que
nous partageons le véritable problème de
santé publique que représente cette
consommation de cannabis
les chiffres évoqués dans ce texte nous
les connaissons tous le cannabis est la
substance psychoactive la plus utilisée
par les français entre 11 et 75 ans 13,8
millions de français ont expérimenté le
produit 1,2 million consomment du
cannabis au moins dix fois par mois
c'est mais c'est le niveau de
consommation de cannabis chez les jeunes
qui place la france au premier rang des
pays d'europe parmi
des jeunes de 17 ans plus de 40 % ont
expérimenté le cannabis et 6 5% en font
un usage régulier et une consommation
problématique
aucun expert aucun addictologue ni ce
que confirment les dernières études
scientifiques la consommation de
cannabis est nocive en particulier chez
les jeunes
les liens entre consommation précoce de
cannabis et risque de troubles
psychotiques sont désormais largement
documenté face à cet enjeu de santé
publique
nous poursuivons tous les mêmes
objectifs réduire les risques prévenir
le plus tôt possible
l'entrée dans la consommation mais il
s'agit également de lutter contre les
trafics contre les réseaux criminels qui
se cache derrière le petit trafic
c'est un enjeu à part entière qui est
indissociable
le gouvernement s'est saisi de ce sujet
le plan gouvernemental de lutte contre
la drogue et les conduites addictives
2013 2017 lancée par le premier ministre
en septembre 2013 comporte des mesures
fortes
ce plan mis en oeuvre par la ville des
cas avec l'ensemble des départements
ministériels mobilise l'ensemble des
leviers la prévention la prise en charge
conjointement sanitaire que social le
développement de la recherche
multidisciplinaire mais aussi la lutte
contre les trafics
je veux citer les mesures suivantes la
priorisation d'actions de prévention et
d'information en direction des jeunes et
de leurs parents
le renforcement des partenariats entre
les professionnels au contact des jeunes
enseignants et personnels de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse et
les consultations jeunes consommateurs
la prise en charge des jeunes
consommateurs les plus en difficulté
dans le cadre des structures de recours
spécialisés avec en particulier le
déploiement de l'approché thérapeutique
familiale dit m dft l'encouragement des
recherches sur les motivations et les
pratiques sociales de consommation de
cannabis chez les jeunes s'agissant de
la lutte contre le trafic
l'intensification de la lutte contre
l'implication des mineures dans le
trafic tant sur le plan de la prévention
que sur celui de la réponse pénale le
renforcement du partenariat entre les
forces de sécurité et les établissements
scolaires pour me
lutter contre le trafic aux abords de
ces établissements la mise en place
d'une surveillance particulière sur les
canaux d'accès à la cannabiculture
magasins spécialisés site internet fret
postal et express la mobilisation de
l'ensemble des acteurs forces de
sécurité locaux et citoyens afin de
lutter contre les effets
déstabilisateurs du trafic local la
poursuite de l'effort en matière de
saisie du patrimoine des trafiquants
dans l'objectif de les priver du produit
de leur trafic
la mise en oeuvre de ce plan s'appuie
notamment sur les professionnels de
santé les travailleurs sociaux qui
oeuvrent dans le champ des addictions
ce sont ces mesures ces actions qui
doivent nous permettre de lutter plus
fortement encore contre ce fléau et
demain mieux protéger la jeunesse de
notre pays
madame la sénatrice vous préconisez avec
cette proposition de loi que la vente de
cannabis à des fins non thérapeutiques
pour ne pas dire récréatif soit
contrôlée par l'état en passant par
l'intermédiaire de débitants comme c'est
le cas pour le tabac en interdisant la
publicité et la vente aux mineurs
les solutions que vous proposez sont
possiblement contre-productive
quant aux objectifs que nous partageons
tout d'abord alors que nous luttons
résolument contre les additifs
d'analyser la consommation de cannabis
nous semble inopportun voire dangereux
ne prenons pas le risque qu'une
libéralisation de visages de cannabis
entraîne une hausse de la consommation
de ce produit
ensuite toute tentative de
dépénalisation de l'égalisation est
susceptible de se heurter à des
stratégies d'adaptation
les organisations criminelles baisse des
prix diversification vers de nouvelles
drogues augmentation de la concentration
du principat fictifs etc
légaliser ou dépénaliser l'usagé de
cannabis diminuerait le niveau des
trafics
c'est méconnaître la motivation et les
motivations du crime organisé dont le
but est le profit sans considération
pour le statut juridique des produits la
contrebande de cigarettes produit légal
dont le trafic génère plusieurs
milliards d'euros par an est là pour en
attester
les filières régulée par la puissance
publique via les normes et des taxes
peuvent aussi jeu
leur propre criminalité le statut de
produit légal ou illicite ne peut à lui
seul expliquer ou empêcher l'existence
de trafic sur cette marchandise à des
initiatives récentes de l'égalisation à
l'étranger on visait à changer la
stratégie dans la lutte contre certaines
drogues et à libéraliser l'usagé du
cannabis
l'uruguay a été le premier pays au monde
à mettre en place un monopole d'état sur
tout le processus de la production
jusqu'à la consommation de cannabis
les états de washington et du colorado
ont procédé à une légalisation du
cannabis pour usage récréatif
ces expériences qui mériteront d'être
restitués dans le contexte de chaque
état sont trop récentes pour permettre
d'en mesurer et d'étudier dans l'étude y
ait des conséquences mais elles sont
dans le débat en 2016 la session
spéciale de l'assemblée générale des
nations unies dédiée à la question des
politiques en matière de drogues
constituera une occasion de débat sur
ces questions plus haut niveau la
mission interministérielle de lutte
contre les drogues et et conduites
addictives est chargé de la coordination
pour la france ce sera donc l'occasion
d'un débat ouvert à partir des
expériences étrangères évaluées
aujourd'hui la question qui doit animer
nos débats et celle d'une part de la
prévention des conduites addictives et
d'autre part de la lutte contre les
réseaux criminels
c'est le choix du gouvernement il
convient de faire de la prévention des
conduites addictives un axe prioritaire
de la politique publique comme l'est
celui de la sécurité routière
il s'agit de promouvoir des programmes
de prévention évalués sur le long terme
en direction des jeunes en misant sur le
développement des compétences
psychosociales et les capacités de
résistance au père la france dispose en
effet d'atouts importants que dans
l'organisation de la prise en charge des
comportements addictifs
chaque personne concernée par une
conduites addictives quel que soit son
âge quel que soit son addiction peut
bénéficier d'une réponse accessibles et
adaptés médecins généralistes soins
spécialisés pour les usagers de
substances psychoactives les centres de
soins d'accompagnement et de prévention
en addictologie
les consultations jeunes consommateurs
qui bénéficie en ce moment d'une
importante campagne d'information
destinée aux jeunes et à leurs parents
les centres d'accueil et
d'accompagnement à la réduction des
risques et enfin bientôt des salles de
consommation à moindre risque
est il opportun de dire qu'au fond le
cannabis ce n'est pas si grave que cela
le cannabis a un impact sur la santé
évidemment moins importants que d'autres
drogues
mais en plus des effets que j'ai déjà
mentionné notamment chez les jeunes
usage de cannabis augmente les risques
de décrochage scolaire et d' accidents
de la route
d'autant plus s'il est associé à
l'alcool cela suffit à justifier la
politique que nous menons pour mettre en
oeuvre des actions et des programmes de
réduction des risques
nous avons besoin de stabilité de
cohérence maintenant le droit tel qu'il
est mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
vous l'aurez donc compris le
gouvernement n'est pas favorable à
l'adoption de cette proposition de loi
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur rachline dont inscrits et pour
3 minutes
monsieur le président madame le ministre
mes chers collègues non la drogue n'est
pas une fatalité comme tenterait de nous
faire croire une telle proposition de
loi la dépénalisation est évidemment une
duperie
car non seulement elle n'arrange pas les
problèmes mais de surcroît elle les
aggrave considérablement tout d'abord
car elle semble présenter le cannabis
comme un produit de consommation au même
titre que l'alcool ou le tabac alors
qu'il est un véritable danger un produit
totalement des structures qui est à la
portée qui est la porte d'entrée vers
l'héroïne et la cocaïne et qui dans
beaucoup de cas va jusqu'à tuer il
n'existe pas de consommation sans risque
des drogues pas même du cannabis
celui-ci vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs
perturbe les fonctions cérébrales réduit
le jugement la concentration et la
mémoire à court terme ainsi que la
capacité d'accomplir des tâches
routinières et il est bien connu qu'en
matière de drogue le consommateur
régulier toujours à la recherche de
sensations plus fortes va de plus en
plus loin en cela les héroïnomanes et
les cocaïnomanes ont toujours commencé
par le cannabis
dès lors face à ces dangers pour la
santé
on ne saurait présenter le cannabis
comme un produit de consommation
courante que l'on achèterait au
supermarché car dépénaliser ces maîtres
la drogue à la portée de tous c'est de
l'inconscience totale
c'est même de l'irresponsabilité à
chaque levée de prohibition des
stupéfiants il y à davantage de
personnes qui prennent de la drogue et
ceux qui sont déjà toxicomanes en
consomme de plus grandes quantités
c'est mettre aussi en grand danger nos
jeunes qui sont très influençables et
très vulnérable face au cannabis
42% des jeunes de 17 ans l'ont déjà
expérimenté et nous aurions pensé à
apporter des solutions à cette ville
n'avaient cette vulnérabilité pardon en
leur proposant du cannabis sur un
plateau d'argent
nous prenons en dépénalisant le problème
complètement à l'envers
quelques et quelle cohérence y at-il à
sensibiliser le jeune public aux effets
néfastes du cannabis
si parallèlement nous en faisons un
produit quasiment légal qui s'achètent
librement il faut vraiment être naïf
pour croire que les groupes criminels
vont se laisser si facilement enlever
les gains immense du trafic
une égalisation accroît de façon
vertigineuse les profits du crime
organisé nous le savons bien
nous en avons à l'étranger de nombreux
exemples en légalisant le cannabis
l'état deviendra le partenaire
commercial des groupes criminels en
réalité la vérité c'est qu'avec cette
proposition le parti écologiste sombre
une nouvelle fois dans la démagogie
cédant à une idéologie libertaire qui
est un danger un vrai danger pour notre
société face à la drogue
il ne faut pas baisser les bras et il
faut réaffirmer qu'elle est un fléau et
qu'il faut la combattre par une lutte
sans relâche des trafiquants qui
gangrène nos villes nos quartiers et nos
écoles s'il faut réduire le marché du
cannabis
il faut le démodé par une plus grande
prévention dès le plus jeune âge une
prévention axée sur la santé sur les
dangers de la consommation du cannabis
qui ouvre les portes à d'autres drogues
expliqué à travers les éducateurs de rue
les témoignages d'anciens toxicomanes
que la drogue n'est qu'un cache-misère
expliqué que les joies éphémères qu'elle
apporte est un leurre qui laisse trop
souvent des relais a derrière lui de la
détresse évidemment nous votre contrat
merci monsieur rachid cher collègue
madame la ministre il est 18h30 les
quatre heures qui était un parti donc à
la niche du groupe écologiste sont
écoulées et je suis donc dans
l'obligation d'interrompre l'examen de
ce texte
voilà pour ces débats dans l'hémicycle
sur la proposition de loi d'esther
benbassa une proposition de loi
emblématique puisqu'elle vise à
autoriser la vente au détail de cannabis
mais dans un cadre strictement contrôlé
une proposition de loi qui a assez peu
de chances d'être adoptée ici au sénat
vous avez pu le voir parler débat assez
houleux des débats qui ont été
interrompus avant la fin de l'examen du
texte la conférence des présidents doit
désormais déterminer une date ultérieure
pour poursuivre ses débats ou pointures
voir et revoir toutes les séances sur
notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée à vous sur les
chaînes parlementaires